I think Star Wars was constructed to let
people live in it however they wanted it
has created a template for us to talk
about all sorts of stuff that affects
politics culture and ideas it sells this
idea that all of this is happening in
some larger world and there was nothing
like this out at the time
what we're talking about in this part of
the thing that we'd like to do at reason
is talk about popular culture not simply
as okay well you know is this movie as
this book is this record good or bad but
you know what's interesting about it how
how are people but the producers but
especially the consumers of something
using it to talk about issues and ideas
that are important to them
all culture is participatory culture now
more than ever and Star Wars is kind of
a fascinating cultural phenomenon going
back now what 30-plus years you know
we're in many ways and you know I'm
happy to take abuse for this in many
ways that is total crap culture it was
the first movie was produced by a
semi-literate guy who but it has created
a template and I don't mean that
disparagingly you know that he was
semi-literate
it has created a template and a kind of
matrix a framework of scaffold for us to
talk about all sorts of stuff that
affects politics culture and ideas and
it's huge it's it's absolutely part of
the everyday fabric of all we talk about
so it deserves attention for that well
beyond a question of whether or not you
think you know the particular camera
work is interesting or the storytelling
is cliched or whatever it is so
important in that way and so with that
as a kind of rambling intro for each of
you what's the what what do you is the
core of Star Wars appeal arguably more
than any other cultural phenomena the
past 40 years Star Wars has captured the
public's imagination and the public's
pocketbook we have in our cover story of
the latest issue of Reason which you can
pick up for free out in the other room
something like forty two billion dollars
of money has been generated out of
George Lucas's vision of the first Star
Wars movie really fascinating but so
Alisa let's start with you what what do
you find so special about Star Wars that
it's still a thriving enterprise years
later well one of the things I think is
fascinating about Star Wars and is that
in many ways that sort of anticipates
the way that culture is created today
right now if you look at the television
business model for example ratings are
down
but a show can survive forever on
incredibly passionate viewers and Star
Wars is sort of an early work in a way
that really leans into fan enthusiasms
but it's constructed in such a way that
there's something there for everyone you
know if you're looking for a strong
female heroine and Princess Leia is sort
of the template that pop culture has
followed for the next 40 years if you
are interested in two big geopolitical
issues you have this fascinating clash
between the Empire and the rebellion if
you're looking for a sort of you know
soft spirit the you know 70s
spirituality the force was literally so
powerful an idea that Francis Ford
Coppola suggested that he and George
Lucas found a real world religion based
on it if you like sort of mannered
British humor you have Anthony Daniels
the c-3po and so it has all of these
different hooks for any you know almost
any particular taste to find itself
represented in the films in the books
not so much in the three prequels but we
can talk about whether those count later
and so it manages to do all of that
without being discordant in a really
interesting way it's a tough act to pull
off that sort of fussy British humor the
big clash is the coming-of-age story
with Luke Skywalker the sort of Rick
Blaine of Hansel and so I mean it's I
notice you're not mentioning the Ewoks
there's a lot of people here it came
tonight for the Ewoks to talk about you
know the Ewoks and imperialism and
counterinsurgency later but that seems
like a subject for a follow-up question
if that's okay with you but then it's
also a franchise that really leans into
popular enthusiasm for right I mean you
know you have this incredible series of
spin-off books and comics and games and
you know in a way that really
anticipates the way video games work
today
it created a world that people could
live in really to the extent of their
interest and ability to buy and store
Star Wars eu novels so they're a
terrifying number of them in my
apartment so it really I think Star Wars
was constructed to let people live in it
however they wanted and
as long as they wanted and it really
anticipated the way that something like
Marvel is spinning out it's you know
expanded universe today or that you know
the Warcraft games let you live in them
forever it really anticipated that need
I think great Thank You Sonny when what
was the first time you encountered Star
Wars do you remember and what did you
find about it yeah no I I came to the
series a little oddly actually I did not
see a Star Wars movie until I was about
ten and it was Return of the Jedi
so I saw them kind of out of order and
then in order and then with all the
prequels but it was it was definitely a
was like a whole so I saw Return of the
Jedi and I had literally no idea what's
going on even more so than people
sitting down to watch you know a new
hope for the first time and I was still
entranced I like made my friend turn it
back on I was like no can we watch that
again I don't want to watch so we're
watching it on like a VCR a yo-yos VHS
yes it was 91 or 92 or so so yeah VHS
I'm like a VHS that was recorded from TV
I mean it was not a it's the a home so
what was it that that captivated you and
made you okay let's watch this again and
again and again you know I mean what
again watching it as a child you have
monsters and you have lasers and you
have a very basic but interesting story
now granted that again seeing it out of
order the kind of hyung Luke Leia
triangle didn't make very much sense to
me but I was like ya know people love
each other
I'm sorry Banksy but it makes even less
sense once you go through puberty yeah
so that was my first experience all
right Peter what about you what what
what is what do you think is the special
sauce that keeps Star Wars front and
center really as a way you know you know
as a text that we're still talking about
yeah I mean a couple of things that both
Sonny Anolis already touched on you know
in particular this idea of a wider world
and Star Wars really sold the idea
especially the first one
the episode 4 which was just you know
New Hope which is the was when it was
released just Star Wars and four years
was known as just Star Wars when you
said Star Wars that's what you're
referring to if you go back and watch
the first 30 minutes of that movie
almost every line and certainly every
sort of major exchange of dialogue
references something else that never
comes back you hear about power
converters at tachi station you hear
about a droid needing to learn to speak
bocce right and like this is all stuff
that is you like why what is bachi what
are what's the binary language
humidifiers are oh Africa what it is
right look all of this stuff that you've
got a like like it sells this idea that
all of this is happening in some larger
world that you can experience and then
that world I mean so that that world is
was expanded upon you know in a lot of
ways with the expanding universe but it
is a world that you can instantly
imagine and sort of it like and you
enter into like flights of sort of
imaginative fancy especially if you are
you know five six eight ten years old so
you're the target audience for those
films the the kids who made that those
movies in that movie in particular
really a huge hit and so I think that
that's that's a big part of it and then
the other thing that I would say is that
you know visually it's incredibly
compelling I went back and I watched the
original trilogy yes the special edition
it's the only thing you can get but like
but most of the shots in that movie it
you know in the special edition are
relatively unaltered they're the
compositions are basically the same and
the compositions in that film are really
incredible and really striking you have
all of these all of these you know stark
black-and-white compositions you have
either these little tiny spaceships
framed against this these huge huge you
know sort of galactic panoramas you have
I mean stuff that is like either that
all the stuff on Tatooine in the
beginning of the beginning of that film
is like kind of in conversation with
Lawrence of Arabia as you it's really
funny right but it's it's it's true
you've got to c-3po like wandering over
these dunes and it's sort of sad and
like where's you know and like it's
cinematically it's really brilliantly
crafted I mean in in some ways
is kind of crap but like the all of the
like you said certain story in terms of
story and and certainly in terms of like
the dialogue and also just to follow up
on the idea of Star Wars being scenes of
it being in dialogue with Lawrence of
Arabia which is certainly the case with
I can remember how many of you
remembered seeing the first Star Wars
movie in the theater anybody else here
you know waiting out you know for hours
online hoping you could get a ticket and
then you would wait for the next show
but those shots of like the the
spaceships kind of slowly cruising by
and it was in it was in conversation
with 2001 Space Odyssey but it was
enjoyable 2001 Space Odyssey is that
kind of it's like an arthouse movie you
know that was big but you you have to
pretend to enjoy it when it came out joy
Space Odyssey was the biggest
science fiction film that had ever been
released and it had it made I don't know
20 30 I mean the typically science
fiction films at the time would bring in
15 to 20 million dollars at the box
office Star Wars you know finished its
box it's run after almost a year with
about two hundred and forty million
dollars in 70s dollars you know when
science fiction was popular but it was a
subculture Star Wars had vanished or a
rather Star Trek and was being you know
kept alive by a remnant that were
writing fanfiction and buying you know
off-brand kind of authorized editions of
things Alisa you were going to say
something both of you were saying I mean
and I should note Star Wars was my
gateway not just a science fiction about
to pop culture I grew up in a house that
for a long time didn't have a television
and was I was basically raised Amish to
a certain extent and so my cousin showed
me the Star Wars movie isn't sort of
introduced me to the whole world but I
think that one thing that underlines
what all three of us are saying is that
the Star Wars movies are actually pretty
smart they demand a fair amount even
from a youthful audience they are
comprehensible but you have to work at
it and think about it a little bit there
are a lot of pre-existing concepts it's
a big universe and so you know the plot
requires a certain amount of political
sophistication it requires a certain
amount of anthropological sophistication
it
works on a number of levels you can
watch the movies when you're 10 and
enjoy the funny robots and monsters and
then you can watch them once you've been
exposed to the Canon of you know Jeeves
and PG woodhouse and find c-3po funny
and try a triumph of the will ultimately
I mean literally the final scene is a
shot-for-shot remake of certain elements
of triumph oh yeah well in the end I
mean it kind of on this line you know
the reason Star Wars has reached a I
think a much broader audience than Star
Trek has is you can enjoy it on both the
shallow plot adventure level and also
like dig down into the kind of like
nerdy who what is the name of the
bartender at Mos Eisley level you know
like so it's amazing is that EU that
doesn't exist anymore well let's let's
uh you know to follow up on this and I'm
gonna ask Peter this to leave the
conversation in this so I mean we we've
kind of started talking about how Star
Wars isn't just phenomenally long-lived
and successful as a movie franchise it's
changed how movies were financed
creative control for these big budget
projects were maintained fans were
engaged spin-off products were license
and distributed Lucas here is less a
storyteller more the creator of a kind
of whole new universe kind of and not
just a storytelling universe but you
know you know you know right things you
could buy I mean it's like the Catholic
Church of movies where you could go out
and buy scapula's you know that the Jedi
might have worn somewhere Peter talked a
little bit about the what what do you
think are the most important aspects of
Lucas's legacy and how he changed the
movie business and other related areas
of creative expression I mean as you
mentioned a bunch of them and there are
so many just a couple that I will name
special effects that the movie was
really the first film to extensively use
computers to do special effects not in
to Jenner not in generating the images
but in controlling the cameras ILM was
founded basically as you spell it out
for people
Industrial Light and Magic which is the
special effects house that is owned by
George Lucas and did the special effects
for Star Wars and is now
one of if not the premier special
effects houses in in Hollywood
what's that part of the deal with Disney
I don't think so much Joan I don't
believe so but I I don't want to swear
to that
fact-check being someone so the special
effects is one component he Lucas really
paved the way for independent creators
and for creative control over product or
for individual creative control over
products in film people think of Lucas
you're funny enough as kind of taking us
out of the era of independent film you
know sort of driven by by creators who
just had their own vision but in fact
she was very much of that era and one of
the big things that he fought for when
he was dealing when he was doing the
contracts and we was getting star wars
started was to own the rights to not
just to the movie but to the sort of the
rest of the universe to have all of the
toy and product and an you know and
ancillary rights and all that and then
when Empire and Return of the Jedi came
out he self financed both of those based
using the profits from and the loans he
was able to get based on the sales from
the first and then the second film and
so that was a big deal and really kind
of built out the market for independent
filmmaking that was all that is either
only somewhat supported or entirely
independent of the studio system in that
and that didn't exist at the time so in
a way I mean he's more of a tourism
quite technically the right chair but
he's more of a cultural and presario or
a serious artist than somebody like
saying like terrence malick or you know
other people who get held up from the
kind of 70s you know maverick movie
business of like I've got my unique
vision and I'm not gonna compromise or
even Woody Allen is kind of like this
but you know where it's Lucas and you
don't think of him first and foremost as
an artist who demands absolute creative
control but he really did and if you
know if you go again go back and watch
the original Star Wars it's bizarre it's
totally weird you've got all these
talking robots and you've got all these
strange aliens and there was no
thing like this out at the time it
wasn't now it feels so normal to us
because a we've all seen that movie a
hundred times I'm sorry I've seen that
movie at least a hundred times and right
and like and every movie since then is
in some ways and indebted to Star Wars
but it was really unusual at a time and
in fact went over budget the board of
the studio that was helping to finance
the first film really didn't believe in
it and only the the CEO of Fox kind of
had to protect him and at one point had
to say you guys have to shut down
filming by this Friday because I have a
board meeting over the weekend and you
will not like at that point I have to
walk into the board meeting and say we
are not filming anymore so whatever it
is you do just finish it by Friday it
was like a he had like three days but
part of what's interesting about this
reputation for Lucas as an author is the
way the expanded universe worked right
because these are and people laugh about
these novels but they kept the franchise
alive for you know years in between
movies and Lucas did what in some ways
is an amazingly generous thing and he
let other authors come in and play in
his universe and some of these book
series are really fun um the Thrawn
Trilogy
which you know posits this sort of half
alien imperial general who is this you
know kind of military genius is really
fun and interesting and gets at a lot of
the racial politics of the Empire the
Rogue Squadron books by Michael
Stackpole who's primarily a videogame
writer are a really fun series of sort
of commando novels that you deep into
the economics of the Empire and that
have a great you know female antihero of
this really fascinating character and so
you know yes Lucas is this
uncompromising I turn a lot of ways but
there's a generous legacy to that as
well and and it's kind of an open source
universe in the sense that at first he
when fans started creating you know kind
of taking mass-produced goods and
refashioning to them
their own ideas he at first was kind of
pushing back then he was like wait this
is this is going to help build the
audience yeah and I mean I think it's
one of the models for you know these
sort of more open universes and for
these creative dialogues within these
properties I mean I think you've you
look at something like the Marvel
Universe today
there is this sense that different
creative voices can be harmonized not
just into a single revision of a
creative universe but into a large
ongoing story that can be sort of
reconciled to itself and that's pretty
similarly exciting things how many
people here have watched some are all of
Jessica Jones you know that's a Marvel
series that's really strikingly
different in tone and theme and
character from everything else but
fortunately they've had the confidence
that it can be done I think in part
because of something like the expanded
universe something yeah it's I mean
what's interesting kind of about Star
Wars is relationship with intellectual
property right is that like on the one
hand Lucasfilm is very protective of
their brand if you try to sell like
knockoff Luke Skywalker's they will put
you in a dumpster and light it on fire
and then sue you and then but on the
other hand you know they they also
there's also a like subculture of people
who make their own stormtrooper uniforms
the five-o first Battalion and Lucasfilm
is totally into that they're like go
ahead go for it you know they don't like
it when people sell the uniforms but if
people are out there making their own
stuff and you know going to charity
events they like it so much that George
Lucas asked them to come out and like
March with Darth Vader at the Rose Bowl
parade a few years back and I mean it's
like it's it's and even judges he has
judged fan film competitions so I mean
it's it's a it's a kind of a it's a very
weirdly split you know like if you're
having fun go for it if you're making a
profit we should probably have a chat
which is also kind of like the Grateful
Dead had this experience where they were
very interested you know they exhorted
people to kind of tape and trade shows
and and various kinds of tchotchkes
memorable
you're not supposed to make money off it
but you know and it seems like a pretty
good compromise section yeah I recalled
one of the very first videos I ever
watched on the internet was in probably
97 or 98 was a short film called I
believe droids in which it was a
basically a cops parody featuring
featuring stormtroopers who were like
hassling Jawas no no you guys and it was
and this was the SIRT this is the sort
of wonderful thing that a movie like
that a movie with all of these kind of
extraneous ideas and this big world
built into it can generate especially
when you do what Lucas did and allow the
fans to participate and be part of the
creative culture behind behind the world
although they were not powerful enough
to get the Star Wars kid in the new
trilogy sadly but well let's go you know
now we're in Washington DC I hope nobody
here has had so much to drink they don't
remember that but you know whatever else
we might say about the the Star Wars
series the six movies and I am probably
hot or quite possibly the only person in
this room who actually prefers the
second three movies for the first three
but whatever else you might say about at
the the six Star Wars movie are also
explicitly political stories they tell
the story of youthful rebellion against
this an essent repressive Empire Sonny
you have written about why the
destruction of Alderaan an entire planet
of people you know they're just flying
kites it's like you know pre and village
in Iraq in the first movie was totally
justified and it's a given if you follow
these things that what is called
neoconservative Twitter loves the
Galactic Empire Bill Kristol the founder
and editor of The Weekly Standard has
even asked what's so bad about the
Empire and one of his staffers over a
dozen years ago Jonathan last literally
made the case for the Empire years ago
so
now most fans disagree with that they're
on the side of the rebels but you know
what where and why are they wrong well
you know it's funny that you say the six
Star Wars movies tell the story of a
youthful rebellion is this a J Empire
and that's actually not true
that's what the that's what New Hope
through Return of the Jedi - certainly
yeah if you if you go back and look at
one through three it tells a very
different story right it tells the story
of kind of a how erotic confident pyre
non-functioning Republican named only
you know a ridiculous situation where
member states are being blockaded by
tread trade Federation's and nobody can
really get anything done in the Senate
and you know you you've you've got but
wait lock is good right I thought
Washington free beacon I don't you're
not saying no you know we should have
more laws being passed okay so what is
what are the politics of star wars then
or do they tell a story that's
meaningful to contemporary America or
the contemporary world I don't know if
they tell a story that is meaningful to
they can tamper I mean it's so it's so
scattershot and ridiculous right like on
the one hand you have the kind of you
have the evil empire which are have been
kind of cast as Nazis right you know and
then you have that's in the first three
movies for sure that starts you know
Darth Vader is Adolf Hitler I don't I
would say more grand moff tarkin is okay
how you how you want okay but the the
airing the the series has always been
kind of split on this right like
Americans have always kind of envisioned
themselves as the rebels fight against
the evil empire but if you look at
Return of the Jedi that's kind of
consciously modeled after the the Ewoks
being essentially Vietcong taking down
the you know mechanized evil destructive
America they're the Vietcong and but you
know and it's so like I
trying to create a sort of sensible
political idea out of this is is a
fool's errand and this is why you can do
things like write a defense of the
destruction of Alderaan and what is that
in one sentence is it they those they
had it coming or well it takes more than
one sentence but I would say it's a
financial and intellectual hub of a
space terrorist organization trying to
let's be clear I assigned Sonny this
piece so I bear much and I mean look so
we sniff on this very stage right the
only reason we have to believe that
Alderaan is peaceful planet is because
Princess Leia says so the Princess Leia
does nothing but lie in that first movie
she lies about the diplomatic mission
she was on spy mission spy mission she
lies about knowing where the Death Star
plans break her shot at her hairstyle to
dress Johnson returned their calls you
know hey that's so Alisa do you think
are there is there a coherent maybe not
a coherent politics to Star Wars but is
something going on there that is also
interesting to contemporary audiences I
mean I think that again one of the
reasons that Star Wars is so persistent
is that it's a broad schema that you can
apply to many different situations right
it's I think it's distinct from pop
culture that is directly and obviously
commenting on real world analogs but it
is a tool that you can use to analyze
all sorts of different debates I mean we
see Star Wars commentary popping up
among the Republican presidential
candidates and that's being you know
treated as a form of political signaling
about how fun people are sort of
authoritarian styles of governing right
I don't actually think that it is a
litmus test for you know where any
Republican candidates stand on foreign
policy although I would really love to
you hear Donald Trump talk about where
he fits into all of this you know that
was job no.1 yeah those those Gungans
you know they're bringing drugs my
guests are good people you know and but
it's it is lasted because it's ask Emma
not because it's direct collector II
Peter what I do I don't I don't take a
side in the Empire you know versus
rebels debate I mean that's like are you
Pro Assad or are you Pro Isis and I like
you as the libertarian in the room like
I feel like you don't have to take a
side and in fact I think that the the
fact that Han Solo and to a lesser
extent bobba fett who are two kind of
independent characters who yes aligned
with both sides but in a lot of ways are
exist outside of the the main conflict
between the rebellion and the Empire and
and kind of have their own agendas the
fact that they have been such popular
and enduring characters shows in in some
ways sort of the shows the appeal of
kind of the independent stand outside of
the this conflict don't want to be a
part of it kind of ethos and like Han
Solo represents that pretty well and in
his own way so does bobba fett right and
yeah I mean this is where to go back to
earlier points I think that all of you
made in different ways this is where
Star Wars is in conversation with
previous pop culture particularly that
baby boomers grew up with you mentioned
Han Solo as Rick Blaine I mean he is
Humphrey Bogart Rick Blaine is the main
character in Casablanca and he's you
know he's done he has no ideals anymore
but he always ends up making the right
moment he'll help you know help be
altruistic for the right cause well one
thing I think it's fascinating that Star
Wars JJ Abrams has remarked that he made
the main character in the force awakens
the forthcoming Star Wars movie a woman
because he wanted to sort of engage
female audiences and I sympathize with
that to a certain extent but the idea
that Star Wars hasn't always been a
Chai's foreign about women it's a little
ridiculous in part because it is
effectively a romance novel right I mean
this is the standard template of a great
female character who has to decide
between two sort of equally worthy but
different male love interest one of whom
is eliminated because he turns out to be
her brother okay five hey you know not
if libertarians get control it'll still
be on the tape is that his principles
are restored to him and he becomes a
better principled more emotionally open
person because he loves Princess Leia
right I mean she restores not just his
sense of connection to other people but
his sense of purpose to him I mean it's
a remarkably sophisticated grown-up
romance and it's I mean it's a great
romantic movie it could be a nap at our
comedy you know I did I thought I
thought JJ Abrams comments were totally
bizarre like I've never I've never met a
woman who liked like action movies
generally who doesn't like Star Wars
like I the idea that women aren't into
it is I don't know maybe but this might
be just being me mansplaining I don't
know no I mean I think it's it's really
bizarre vulture has a video out today
that's like all of the lines by women
other than Princess Leia that are spoken
in Star Wars there are not many lines
spoken by people outside of the core
three or four characters in the movie
it's I mean it's a remarkably focused
you know character study for through the
first three movies of the franchise you
know you you have your side players but
it's a it's a weird sort of retroactive
rewriting of the movies a sexist that
never really makes sense to me
especially since the leader of the
rebellion is a woman I'm sorry like and
it's also true in the second trilogy I
mean Natalie Portman the Queen is all
over the place too as well again like
really the central character in many
ways yes and I don't I mean she
basically dies of sadness during
childbirth which maybe
my keys in it can you imagine being
Darth Vader's wife I mean I'm sorry he
would be he's a good earner we could do
worse driver I bet you could have a
pretty nice apartment on Khorasan are
you looking forward to the force awakens
do you think it'll be a good movie and
why I think it will probably be an
entertaining film because JJ Abrams
tends to make entertaining films it has
to be good because if it is not I will
take to my bed for the next six months
Peter yes I'm looking forward to it and
I'm hopeful it's good
Wow okay well I want to thank our
participants and thank you for coming
from reason thank you